if you just looked at a handful of these
prices over the last 10 years you could
actually tell a story that linked
together
uh the arab spring revolutions the civil
war in syria
brexit the rise of trump the rise of
right-wing populism the collapse of
venezuela the u.s border crisis the war
in ukraine uh the complete destruction
of cities such as mosul and not just
that but also things like spikes and
civil uh spikes in wars such as in
somalia even the so-called climate wars
in kenya and so just by looking at these
numbers i found that i could tell a
story a kind of a new story of if you
like a kind of a global butterfly effect
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kissing
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people our brilliant guest today is the
author of price wars how chaotic markets
are creating a chaotic world rupa
russell welcome to trigonometry thanks
for having me it's great to have you on
the show tell everybody a little bit
about who you are how are you where you
are what has been the journey through
life that brings you to be sitting here
talking to us
sure so
my first career was in academia i
formed here but i went to the states for
around 10 years i did a phd sociology
and i was frustrated with academia
because there's lots of great ideas lots
of interesting things going on great
research but it found it very insular it
was sort of academics talking to other
academics and if you
even suggested doing things that were so
called popular that was like seen as
taboo and
not something you want to even talk
about if you were interested in getting
tenure track and then tenure et cetera
one does not talk to the plebs
precisely that was what was communicated
to me repeatedly
well now you're here and you're doing it
that is what i wanted so this is the
goal achieved so
i wanted to finish though so i finished
my phd and i decided i wanted to take
some fascinating ideas i come across and
one of those ideas was from my advisor
or andrew patterson who
had done some incredible research on the
idea of freedom
um looked at the origins of freedom and
slave societies looked at how freedom
had spread through western culture over
the centuries but also how americans
viewed freedom he had commissioned
enormous sort of survey research to sort
of see what americans thought and
i thought this was a really fun topic to
delve into
the iraq war was nearly a decade old at
this point around 2013-14
so why not make a film about freedom
what is freedom
uh what does it mean different parts of
the world when people say they're
fighting for freedom what do they even
mean and so the film ended up being a
kind of
a survey so i
the practice of freedom so i wasn't
interested in asking people to define
feedback interested in people who said
they were fighting for freedom and it's
like okay what do you do so in japan
that was uh people who were fighting for
the right to dance dancing had been
banned in nightclubs in much of japan
and so there was you when i went to
tokyo i noticed this because you used to
see signs on the side of the wall that
said no dancing or we thought it was
some kind of ironic hipster thing and
then they were like no no no that you
actually can't dance here and it's a
nightclub as a dj and everyone has to
stand still
and so we did a story on the kind of
movement to sort of campaign for people
to dance we also did some more weight
weightier things like uh the first wave
of the umbrella revolution in hong kong
2014. we went to tunisia to look at the
aftermath of the arab spring what
happens when you've so-called gained
freedom right
in in in that country which at the time
was seen as the kind of success case of
the arab spring revolutions with the
stuff on black lives matter and so forth
and what we found doing this was that
was it didn't matter if you're in east
asia the middle east america
freedom was very much tied up with the
fight for rights and the fight for
democracy
um of course there's like in the details
things may differ but on the whole
people want to be able to say what they
want to say they want to be able to vote
they want to be able to be treated like
an adult they don't want to live
underneath a corrupt regime we found
these all be pretty universal
uh things that people wanted
um and then of course so he was sort of
identifying what was driving that was a
drive towards a liberalism at the time
there was a big discourse around the
drive towards a liberal democracy or
other people called it electoral
authoritarianism there's a
bunch of different jargon around it
but
we didn't
identify why this was happening and this
became more urgent as kind of time went
on so
uh trump wins the united states brexit
happens in the uk there's a right-wing
populist turn in europe so as we were
finishing the film we sort of identified
this trend but
and described it in with these wonderful
characters and gone lots of protest
movements and i got tear gas at donald
trump's inauguration and but we i think
the why was missing and so that brought
me onto this project which is looking at
uh the tumult of the last decade the
2010s and what i kind of identified as
being a key causal factor in this was
prices right prices are international
they're global
that is why you can tell a global story
about global trends because the economy
is essentially global and it's not
global in the sense that it's kind of
amorphous and diffuse and we're all sort
of trading in this sort of big global
market it's global in a very specific
sense in the sense that the price for
traded goods such as uh wheat oil
natural gas now even things like coal
we're hearing about in the news these
will have one price around the world or
one kind of gold price and this price
may differ region to region depending on
literally moving it transportation
costing things like that but there's one
price and this price is kind of set
quite literally at the exchanges the
london metal exchange in london we've
been hearing about nickel prices going
haywire but also in chicago the chicago
mercantile exchange
um and so what i found was that if you
just looked at a handful of these prices
over the last 10 years you could
actually tell a story that linked
together uh the arab spring revolutions
the civil war in syria
brexit the rise of trump the rise of
right-wing populism the collapse of
venezuela the u.s border crisis the war
in ukraine uh the complete destruction
of cities such as mosul and not just
that but also things like spikes and
civil uh spikes in wars such as in
somalia even the so-called climate wars
in kenya and so just by looking at these
numbers i found that i could tell a
story a kind of a new story of if you
like a kind of a global butterfly effect
that have been happening through these
prices they're all visible we see them
every day but they have been moving in i
would say quite volatile and sometimes
mysterious ways and what ended up
happening was it created enormous shocks
globally so when the price of food or
oil in particular the only ones but
those in particular move violently
either up or down creates enormous
instability and the way you can think
about it is like a pandora's box right
so it's not that the prices are like
literally driving tanks or they're
literally impoverishing people it's that
they're kind of creating fractures in
the society politically socially
economically and from that it allows a
kind of pandora's box to sort of open of
course isis is probably the worst but
maybe the most prescient right now is
vladimir putin and so the way that i
kind of described this was
whether i kind of thought about
geopolitics by by the end of it was that
we like to tell kind of monster stories
right and this will
view us this will differ who you may
think the monsters are but for some
non-controversial examples we could pick
putin isis for example it would be the
too big was
in in china maybe you know maduro and
venezuela
um
and
you know there's there's a lot of
psychologising that goes on what's putin
really thinking about what's isis's true
ideology
and that's fair enough i think well
nothing wrong with that but i'm
definitely not a criminologist i don't
know what some putin's had i don't
really think anybody really knows apart
from putin but we could i think it's
also fair to assume just for argument's
sake that it's nefarious right we can
kind of assume that isis wants to
dominate its neighbors putin wants to
dominate its neighbors but these uh
people are just made of flesh and bone
right so it's not literally putin
driving a tank he's not literally
godzilla marching down to a border and
destroying it
it's it's all enabled by not just the
economy but in particular for those two
cases in particular oil and gas right
and that these people get strengthened
when oil and gas prices are high so the
way that i sort of began to see it was
that the global economy and the
commodity markets in particular kind of
create an architecture a kind of
labyrinth around the world
and
for the most part these monsters tend to
be contained so you know putin may have
been wanting to invade ukraine over the
last seven years for example right he
started the conflict 2014
um and it's been interesting that there
hasn't been much happening right when i
was there in 2018
you know it was old news it was five six
years there were still trenches being
dug out everybody was hoping it would
end but nobody kind of knew why
and so it's like well why didn't you do
it and the argument of the book is it's
because the low oil prices in that seven
year period essentially encaged him
right and you can kind of tell the story
about how you have these price changes
or price shocks and they're constantly
opening and closing gates around the
world and when they open we get these
monsters they go and kind of roam around
they create enormous destruction and
then the economic conditions may change
and then they kind of get closed up
again so
the the sort of the the argument that i
sort of arrived at was that we have this
sort of
invisible architecture kind of all
around us and that's what's been driving
the kind of ordering
chaos of the last 12 14 years now
so you talked about oil prices and that
sort of makes sense when people who who
profit from the sale of oil and gas have
more money they're more able to execute
plans that they otherwise would have
done but they didn't have the money and
and the sort of confidence in the future
to execute
um what about food prices because that's
obviously becoming a big conversation
particularly now only because people in
the west are suddenly starting to
realize that food prices also affect
them right yeah precisely so we've had
two major food price bikes in the last
uh uh 20 or so years so one was 2008
one was 2010.
and when you it sort of looks like kind
of double dip like this right and this
is an index created by the un called the
un uh food price index and what you see
is as soon as these prices start go
going up and got a long story short
essentially doubling in both these
periods to where they had been
previously
um you essentially see especially when
you get to the peaks enormous riots
breaking out everywhere so essentially
what ends up happening in 2008 half the
globe was called the global food crisis
the u.n declares this food prices
essentially double
um 155 million people are pushed into
extreme poverty you see a surge in
protests and riots and a few governments
get deposed we then have the financial
crisis happens essentially immediately
it was already starting but it becomes
kind of global recession by 2009
this creates another wave of poverty and
hunger throughout the world
and then 2010 is almost like if you're
like the third hit so food prices then
surge for
a second time and it becomes like a
third stressor and this is when you
begin to see you know not just riots and
revolutions in the middle east but
actually globally amongst a lot of food
importers you begin to see this and it's
not difficult to understand why right we
don't need to be mechanistic about it
either it's not just that people
you know can't afford food or can't
afford to eat and therefore they go out
to protest
in many of these countries um there's a
kind of
they're quite a ruling bargain or like a
social contract right and often so just
in the tunisia case you know there's a
kind of uh
an idea that okay yes then the dictator
ben ali and his family may go off and
have nice you know trips to san tropez
and they we kind of know they're
stealing some money and they've got the
nice yachts and they've got the nice
palaces but in return for this
um
there has to be a guarantee a guarantee
that life is livable and that is usually
expressed itself through
a combination of bread prices
controls that is and sort of a wage or
minimum income level essentially and
it's a combination of these things and
this dates back to the end of the second
world war so when the colonial powers
collapse the new revolutionary
governments come in and say india or
egypt also tunisia
and they and they say all right it's
part of kicking out the colonizers we're
gonna we're gonna guarantee your life
it's livable and of course they may be a
bit autocratic
but there's this social contract and so
though so we're gonna we're gonna be the
dictator in charge our family is gonna
profit but in exchange you're gonna get
stability yeah you're gonna get security
if you don't speak out against the
regime and blah blah blah and most
importantly you're going to get a stable
predictable income which can and you'll
be able to buy food with it and that's
the deal yeah that's right so it's also
the way i put it it's it's it's
sustenance it's about thirty five
percent four to forty percent of most
caloric intake in the middle east is
from wheat bread and so forth but it's
also symbol right so also it's a symbol
of this ruling uh contract a ruling but
bargain and that's why it's so
combustible so when you look at for
example the photographs these are being
produced people are holding bread right
so in syria yeah you see lions people
walking and they're holding a bread the
same as in yemen in tunisia there's
photographs of people holding baguettes
you know there's kind of guns at the
police so bread takes on a kind of jewel
function but it's also similar here
right so not all prices are politically
important um in the in america in
particular you know gas prices have
enormous outsized political effects
um and of course housing as well was to
be a third one of which house prices
were kind of obsessed with so it's not
necessarily the most important prices
uh are the ones that get picked up of
course there's lots of prices that go
into our living standard but politically
some kind of tend to get emphasized
it's
very very interesting to talking about
this talking about food prices because
uh this is something that has affected
me
directly you mentioned venezuela that's
where my mother's from okay so i've seen
what happens when food prices spiral
when
you you get hyperinflation you talk
about hyperinflation in venezuela in
your book
let's let's discuss a little bit about
that what effect does hyperinflation
have on society and what effect does it
have on ordinary people
god that is a big question i will
um the effect it has on society is it
created turns life into a sort of
topsy-turvy
escher-like labyrinth so
i'll tell you
uh two stories so one is what
hyperinflation looks like so if you're
standing in in caracas it looks like
you know it could be any south american
city i guess it will set at least of an
l.a it looks a bit like l.a what kind of
concrete brutalist buildings there's
some mountains there's some palm trees
there's street vendors selling fruit and
so forth and everything kind of looks um
you know pretty pleasant and you know
you wouldn't know this place was
necessarily in the midst of like one of
the most brutal economic catastrophes
maybe in history
but then you start looking closer and
it's all in the details so for example
my translator said she doesn't go look
at that lemonade guys so he takes me
over and there's a guy with a white
lemonade stand
um and he's just got you know bucket
lemonade that he's made he's got a
little picture he's gonna put it in
glasses glasses people to come and buy
on the streets it's hot and he's then
got the prices and if you and he was
doing something so he turned out i
looked closer he was writing and he's
writing a new price and he said cuts out
with some scissors and then he was
taking it and putting it on the front
and then the front is paper mache so
he's just sticking prices on top of
prices all day
and that's what he'll do throughout the
day so he knows that prices are going to
double by the afternoon right this is
what economists call inflation's
expectations so that's what everyone
always freaks out about because once it
gets built in no one has to tell him
he's not like i don't know looking at
the newspaper to see what inflation is
he just knows they're going to double by
the afternoon so you should get this so
you get this uh the self-reinforcing
basic exactly becomes self-reinforcing
and it becomes becomes sort of built
into the society
one person i spoke to i'll just give you
his his story his name was octavio and
he was a middle-class kind of uh
nor middle-class guy he was super
interviewed playing video games
um and when the crisis really got going
he
uh couldn't afford to eat now what
happens in what happened in venezuela
when i was there people would talk about
is that
most jobs
that
you would expect to get minimum wage
right and the way that they talk about
it is it's for the month so they would
say okay you're going to get so many
boulevards for the month
that was when i was there um a bus fare
for one day right so a job makes
completely no sense because your month's
wages you would spend just getting to
the job in the morning of one day so
your kind of regular economy is
completely useless to you why it's it's
it's it's a it's a negative sum to
participate in it
and so what he did is he just basically
did nothing he lay on his bed
and he said i'm just gonna get up once a
day to drink a glass of water
and he held up these huge t-shirts and
they were literally like parachutes like
you know he was a fat guy he was a big
guy
in the in the kind of before times and
he just shrank and you saw him and he
just looked like surgery photographs
just a different person and he was just
like completely emaciated he just lost
like kilo after kilo after kilo starving
and
he said he eventually realized that from
his previous life playing world of
warcraft that he could make money
playing world of warcraft and by money
means dollars really so there's a thing
called farming people who who don't know
where you can essentially do the boring
bits of the game
um for uh essentially often it's
americans but it could be people in
britain as well you're chopping virtual
wood collecting virtual blah blah blah
and then you can sell it to people who
can't be bothered to do themselves they
he took over their avatars to do that as
far as i understood how it works and
they would pay him a dollar a day and he
said to me this is amazing i earn as
much as a lawyer or doctor in venezuela
but then once he goes when he gets those
dollars and he converts them into
boulevards becomes a race against time
right because the lemonade guy they're
immediately losing value every single
moment he has it and you're also in a
place with extreme shortages so he would
be running from supermarket to
supermarket looking for canned goods
because he doesn't have the money for to
pay the electricity for a fridge
so he'd want to get rice tuna fish in
the first supermarket you may go to have
tuna fish if you get the next one and
then by the third one you can't afford
it
right so when i say this let this sort
of escher like labyrinth these people
live in these worlds that are literally
turned upside down and in his case it
was like
you know he was in the video game it's
like it becomes a video game that you
can't win you know in the sense that the
architecture around you is just
completely shifting and it just
completely debases your life you know to
to living a life that almost isn't worth
worth living and that also affects the
world as a whole because i know for a
fact that venezuela has a i think the
largest migrant population in the world
5.5 million people have left venezuela
and obviously they're all going to go
somewhere and the reality is is that
most of them will go if they can the
west hey francis do you go on the
internet to look at naughty stuff
yeah is it stuff that you'd be
embarrassed to show your friends
yeah is it stuff that would get you
cancelled yeah well next time you decide
to be naughty and watch more
trigonometry you need to use expressvpn
it doesn't matter mate because i use
incognito mode
it doesn't matter what mode you use or
how many times you clear your browsing
history your internet service provider
can still see every single website
you've ever visited that's why even when
you're at home you should never go
online without using expressvpn my
career is finished they're there you'll
have to leave trigonometry can't be
helped anyway it doesn't matter who your
internet service provider is isps in the
us can legally sell your information to
ad companies expressvpn is an app that
reroutes your internet connection
through their secure service so your isp
can't see the site you visit absolutely
fastest expressvpn also keeps all of
your information secure by encrypting
100 of your data with the most powerful
encryption available
most of the time you won't even realize
you have expressvpn on it runs
seamlessly in the background and is so
easy to use all you have to do is tap
one button and you're protected what am
i gonna do
expressvpn is available on all your
devices phones computers even your smart
tv so there's no excuse for you not to
be using it go on francis do the last
bit
you don't want to end up like me protect
your online activity today
with a vpn rated number one by business
insider
visit my exclusive link
expressvpn.com
trigger and you can get an extra three
months free on a one-year package that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-v-p-n
[Music]
dot com slash trigger expressvpn.com
trigger to learn more
i think most venezuelans have gone to
neighbouring countries so i interviewed
a woman um who were just putting her
last kid on the bus i think it was to
ecuador she had three kids one was in
spain
one was in peru and the third one she
was sending ecuador and she was just
like this is my life now right i'm a
single mom
and now i have to spend my other day
alone i can't there's no there's no
future for me because i've just got my
whole family has been sort of completely
completely
fragmented and but again that affects
you know the neighboring countries which
in turn affects their economies
and the the worrying thing is is
it's unsustainable
we surely we can't keep having this
because then there's going to create
problems in in other economies
and it's going to destabilize their
their populations as well
well that's why the way in which
i was thinking about this in in the book
was it's why chaotic markets create a
chaotic world right so if you're
constantly creating instability in the
world right whether so i also looked at
you know collapsing coffee prices
sending hundreds of thousands of
watermelon migrants this is 2018 to the
u.s border right whether it's volatile
um food prices in africa sending people
to to europe right you're right this
like
you're right this is causing a lot of
instability is it unsustainable i don't
know right we don't we haven't we
haven't reached the limit we don't know
what is sustainable and is and is
unsustainable is it disturbing does it
create disorder absolutely right this is
it's definitely disorder making but i
think the i think the other way that we
may want to think about this is you know
who benefits from this right are there
people who profit from their being
aboard a crisis other people who profit
from migrant flows and this and the
other question is is is other people who
are causing the chaos
that we haven't touched on yet a lot of
the book looks at the nature of these
markets i was about to ask you about
that yeah and you know how did they
how are they impacted by this so what
i'm trying to do in the book is pull
together these things that all seem
quite disparate right so you've got u.s
border crisis
central america climate change coffee
production
speculation and what i'm what i've been
trying to do is is drawing all these
lines between like yes like when when we
hear headlines about migrants crossing
the boat coming to britain we don't hear
the story necessarily of where they've
come and even if we do we don't
necessarily hear why those wars have
started who's giving them weapons yemen
would be a nice example of that right
maybe britain stopped selling saudi
arabia billions of dollars of arms
export every single year maybe those
people on those boats wouldn't be here
because their houses wouldn't been blown
up by saudi bombers right
so
what i'm trying to do in this book is to
tell the story of the last 10 years and
draw all of these connections so that we
go behind the headlines of the immediate
tragedies which is which obviously we
need to do something about to where it
kind of all started the very source of
the chaos itself so well let's do that
then because
you're talking about the volatility and
food and uh resort energy prices
essentially yeah um
and one of the things that human beings
came up with a certain time ago to deal
with the fact
that farmers producing crops
were struggling to get a fair price for
their product because it all arrives at
once and it has to be sold quickly was
human beings invented this great thing
which we now call derivatives right a
way of managing future risks and
managing prices
and initially it was attached to
the actual product
uh but then it evolves you talk to us
explain to people who have no idea about
how financial markets work all of that
from the beginning okay
well in ancient greece um i think modern
modern derivative markets especially in
the states uh come from chicago right so
as you said mid 19th century chicago
it's bang in the center of the midwest
it's where they grow all the wheat other
crops other agriculture and the farmers
would take that you have the harvest you
take everything to chicago
um and there's a problem right there's
massive over supply in chicago and so it
becomes worthless so you know economics
101 supply goes up price goes down and
so it's more profitable just to dump it
into lake michigan right because at
least you might maintain some kind of
assembly price and so what was sort of
one of the innovations that came up with
to sort of run these markets effectively
was was futures right it can sound a bit
confusing
but essentially it just means you you
agree on a a price for a future date so
it's like seller it's like saying you
know i'm going to come and deliver
so many bushels of wheat to chicago
um in may and there's a price for what's
called a may contract or june contract
or a july contract and so it it it it
means that the farmers aren't all coming
to chicago at one in one go and it means
that they can kind of stagger it out so
it gives the farmers security they know
they when they plant those seeds and
do whatever you do to grow wheat
something smell on this parmet i guess
get your
19th century combine harvester out you
know that you've got a guaranteed a
guaranteed price now the problem with
that system
um at least when it very first started i
mean it's true now as well but the
problem is is that there might not be
someone to buy that july contract right
so people ordinary consumers say or a
hotel a bakery a restaurant whoever it
may be back then you may they might not
want to be thinking about buying
something a year a year in advance and
so that's kind of where speculators came
in right and so the idea was it could be
another person could come in and they
could say okay i'm going to guarantee
that price view here's a contract
because here's a piece of paper right
this is what derivatives are it's a
paper derived from the has its value
derived from the bushel of we and i'm
going to do that and then when it then
comes around to july that hotel owner
may say oh actually i do need some wheat
now right and then you can then sell
that onto the onto the hotel right so
there to provide what economists call
liquidity it just means literally the
the grease and the wheels to get the
whole kind of machine working and to
kind of make sure the farmers always
have something to sell to and at the
same time the bakers always have a
steady supply of of wheat that they can
kind of buy for and in that system it
should be said that the speculator in
the middle is playing an important role
because they're taking on a risk that's
right by promising to give you a certain
price for your wheat
a few months or a few years even down
the line they're taking on a risk the
price of wheat may go down the price
that we may go up the demand for wheat
may go down the demand for we may go up
so they're playing a useful role in that
situation okay yeah exactly and they
would also get a discount for that
called the risk premium yeah right so so
they they perform this role and they get
a discount and that's kind of where they
would where they would make
make their money but since then the
world's almost done almost immediately
it's disaster right so this kind of idea
of being a risk mitigation system turns
into a gambling system right because
gambling and risk is essentially the
same thing right so people don't often
it can be conceptually hard to think
about this but imagine like
you get fire insurance out on your house
it's essentially a bet about whether
your house is going to burn down right
you're kind of gambling on this and you
and the insurance company take
opposing sides of this bet just as in
these contracts you have opposing sides
as well right
um
and
you know because before this system you
know imagine um
trying to speculate on the what on the
on the price of wheat right you would
have to like
get a farm with a big storage thing
you'd have to get it all in there you
have to make sure nobody nicked it
nobody burned it down that it was
characterized
it's a complete pain in the ass right so
this is this would this would be a
problem right this is true for anything
whereas what's so the magic of
derivatives is saying well actually we
can bet on the prices of these things
without having to go through the
rigmarole of actually storing these
things and so forth it becomes a number
on a piece of paper it becomes exactly
so we sort of
that's this is the thing about risk and
gambling is that this is there's such a
great promise here for peace and order i
have to say it does actually eventually
work actually do figure it out so
the the uh throughout the
later parts the 19th century in the
early 20th century you have all kinds of
speculative main years that happen i
mean it's not every year but there'll be
somebody will kind of come in and try
and corner the market for pork bellies
or wheat or whatever it may be butter
and they'll kind of come in they'll try
and buy up the supply and send the price
up and
eventually this gets so out of control
that uh roosevelt comes in and regulates
it
and one of the most important
regulations that comes in is they
essentially limit the amount of
speculation right they say okay
um
speculators are important we still want
you around you have this important
function to keep the market kind of
ticking over and take on risk and we're
going to limit you to about 20 of the
market so in the jargon they call it
open interest
and it's incredibly successful right you
know it has to i want to stress that
right from the roosevelt era through to
the end of the 20th century to 2000
commodity prices are actually
pretty stable unless there's a global
mega shock right so the obvious examples
would be in the 70s the opec embargoes
or the iranian 1979 revolution where you
see these huge oil price spikes
but by 1980
3 4 oil prices sort of stabilize
new non-opec producers come in the u.s
starts making more in the uk we have
north sea oil right so the diver the
supply gets diversified the power of
opec comes down and markets are actually
pretty
um pretty good at performing this
function right so if prices go up a
little bit that's a signal to the market
you need to start shoving some more
supply in here and voice first if they
kind of dip down then it's like we
should scale back production
and so from around
1984 to 2004
um
markets are you know ticking over right
you we have actual real global shocks in
this period collapse of the soviet union
the gulf war bush's invasion of iraq the
rise of the asian tigers right there's a
lot going on in the collapse of
communism there's a lot going on in
terms of real-world volatility but you
know to the market's credit they
actually respond in a kind of way we
would want them to in a kind of rational
way finding new supply moving it around
the first gulf war creates a very short
super spike and uh bush's war uh in 2003
is actually barely registers in the oil
price it's actually incredible to think
now with what's happening to oil prices
in 2003 there's some
the
because the sort of the market
anticipated that bush would keep all the
oil flowing they didn't the market the
prices didn't didn't spike at all and
actually osama bin laden gives a really
angry interview to cnn and goes it's an
absolute disaster oil should be a
hundred dollars about it was one of his
like big complaints about the the us he
believed that the us was kind of bribing
saudi to keep the oil twice low and
starving muslims of their deserved oil
riches and so he was he was really angry
about this um but then what we see
around 2005
is this new era of kind of commodity
price um volatility
why does that happen
it's a controversial question and you
will get a lot of different answers from
different people
but from what i ended up speaking to a
lot of traders on background as well as
um some nobel prize-winning economists
it seemed to me that the driver was
simply this this regulatory change in
2000 right this to me seemed like the
most plausible reason as i said it
wasn't like the period before was super
well didn't have real world volatility
it did the markets operated correctly
but in 2000 there was a bill called the
commodity futures modernization act and
what it was really about was a whole new
set of derivatives right so you and your
uh viewers may have heard of credit
default swaps those lovely things that
are the main character in the big short
which were sort of derivatives that
allowed you to bet on housing
essentially right and that was really
what was being created in the 1990s
right there were these all this housing
collateralization assets they were
essentially turning lots of different
things in the real world of which
housing became the most important
um so you were not look and and in some
ways the real thing was that you were no
longer betting even on something to
which had a physical connection you were
quite often betting on a bet that
someone else had made as well when you
with some of these derivatives that's
absolutely true and a part of what
a part of what happened i think
the way to think about it in terms of
scale right so there's always a kind of
fictional nature to these contracts
always ever since the beginning that's
not necessarily what's dangerous about
them
the i think
what i found was that the danger and the
volatility comes from two sources
so one source is just simply the scale
so in that roosevelt era
um of kind of peace and stability that i
like to see it as the speculators were
limited to 20 so you've got a function
in the market it's important but looking
at the physical traders people actually
you know grow we buy wheat turn it into
bread etc they're really going to
dominate the market and they're going to
dominate price because they should know
right they're the ones who are actually
buying and selling it to consumers
post 2000
as i said what they were really trying
to focus on was essentially protect
these new housing derivatives and others
from
any kind of regulation and commodities
were almost like an afterthought right
so commodities kind of get tacked in on
this of like okay well since we're doing
all derivatives you might as well just
bring in oil and metals to go to go with
it and then the speculators in in those
markets can kind of grow to 80 90
percent and so
the original
sort of milton friedman idea of of of
why markets are gray or hayak right
these are your neoliberal uh sort of
economist philosophers is what they'll
say is they'll say well there is my
markets are great because they're
decentralized and you've got ordinary
people on the ground whether you're a
farmer or whether you're a hairdresser
or whatever it may be whatever your
occupation is you know your business
better than anybody else and you're
dealing with supply and demand on a
direct way and that's why prices are
great right because you don't have some
central committee sitting in moscow or
washington dc or london telling everyone
how the economy should work right
there's no commissars in the market but
ironically what this new financialized
market was actually was resembles that a
lot more right because suddenly you've
got people who would dominated the
market 80 90 percent who don't farm
right don't know what a bag of sugar
might even look like may have never even
seen one right don't even know what the
difference between different kinds of
crude oil maybe maybe they do maybe they
don't it doesn't really even matter but
these people kind of dominating and
either people who are living in
singapore hong kong london new york and
suddenly it's their ideas and their
expectations to end up driving it and
the thing about this
is that when you've got these small
groups of uh uh
people who all talk to one another
they're very uh vulnerable to narratives
stories right and you'll see this in the
financial press all the time right
you'll see this in bloomberg the
financial times you'll see you know
there'll be a new story about um
just to take recent examples they'll be
like right all the russian oil's
embargoed and then you'll see the oil
price literally jump 30 dollars a barrel
right which is like completely crazy i
had speculators talk to me about
an event in 2014 when isis moved into
mosul it was headline used oil jumped
five dollars a barrel that was
conseena's unprecedented volatility and
that was what seven eight years ago now
we're jumping thirty dollars a barrel
and it's it's not just human beings it's
also algorithms it's traders it's it's
it's algorithms reading the news that
are reading those headlines before the
human beings even seen them and then the
next day you might have a headline that
goes no actually it's fine india's gonna
buy russia's oil or china's gonna buy it
and then the professor kind of collapses
again and so what you have
is in the
in economic strike when you cause
positive feedback right so you end up
having is whether it's ai whether it's
human beings whether it's trend
followers whether it's index investors
whoever i spoke to
what it ended up being was that you have
these overreactions so when there's a
story of scarcity in the future this
sends the price
higher than it might should be and like
and like vice versa and so that's really
what we're kind of seeing in the last in
the last uh couple of weeks the other
thing that's that's did we just
other things that's that's dangerous
about these derivatives is
you have this kind of volatility side
where things swing up and down the other
side is you often might hear this idea
of explosions right so warren buffett
said derivatives weapons of mass
destruction that's something slightly
different
where he's talking about
um derivative contracts that are
hundreds of pages of long right so when
you're selling wheat and oil on the
whole not always but on the whole you're
dealing with a standardized contract
right everyone knows what it is for
everyone in the market whether you've
got an oil tanker or you're an oil man
or you're a hedge fund trader we know
what this means you're going to get so
many barrels of oil on this date for
this price
those kinds of
the other derivatives these sort of new
ones that were coming up in the 1990s
were hundreds of pages of long 100 long
no one understood them nobody understood
how they really even operated and what
often would happen is that sort of
buried in them somewhere there were
these clauses that would detonate right
so is this you sort of see this in the
big short right i think it's chris
bale's character forgotten whose thing
it says i've just discovered that if
these you know it's a derivative it's an
asset if it's eight percent default the
whole thing blows up it was and he was
autistic right because he actually read
it and all the other characters are
going you actually read this stuff right
so those are the i'll let you go back to
you so so those are the two ways in
which these are sort of destructive and
my book really kind of
focuses on the former which is the
market overreacting to news creating
creating completely unnecessary
volatility it to me it just highlights
and i'm going to look at because i'm not
an economist i've been following
everything you're saying
my question is very much about the human
element of this and societal you have
these tiny fraction of people percentage
of people this tiny part of society
which dictates to everybody else
what kind of society they're going to be
in prices isn't that just phenomenally
dangerous
well i think it has been very dangerous
yes i mean again it's it's interesting
when i went back and i read you know the
original hayak and the original milk
mills and friedman
their promise of markets and this is of
course during the cold war right so
their promise of like a global
capitalist marketplace was
decentralization that was the whole idea
it was you know friedman um uh hated
central bankers he wanted to replace the
federal reserve with a computer he
wanted to abolish the imf i mean he
really genuinely didn't like technocrats
and being told what to do but then i
think it's one of the great ironies is
that
is that what neoliberalism turned into i
think by the end of the 1990s was this
something quite different to what they
had in mind right which was which was to
be dominated by finance and by finance i
mean banks hedge funds other others
where it could be university endowments
it could be um
pension funds asset managers
and these people kind of
begin sort of dominating markets in ways
that wasn't really anticipated friedman
writes a really interesting article i
think it's in 1962 where he is opposed
to central bank independence right and
the reason why he's opposed to it is he
goes who's going to staff the central
banks it's going to be other bankers and
they're just going to govern in the
interest of bankers and friedman's whole
mo was i don't want any interest group
running the market again he wants to
decentralize
um
he isn't actually entirely consistent
later in his in his life he kind of
comes around to greenspan but that's
also why he spends a lot of time trying
to make sure that that that the federal
reserve is run by a computer because he
anticipates that when central banks or
other institutions sort of get staffed
by people they're going to pick people
from finance and those people are going
to want to help to expand the financial
markets
um and essentially what you've ended up
with today is you know uh blackhawk huge
asset manager i think has uh 20 trillion
dollars underneath asset management
right
just for reference i think u.s gdp is 24
25 trillion so you've got
one fund in control of the amount of
money which is nearly the size of the
u.s economy right this is we are almost
in like we're back to the kremlin right
we're back to a commissar in charge of
hospitals schools veterinary clinics
restaurants i mean you name it these
asset managers own it and so i think
it's one of the great ironies is that of
of the kind of neoliberal project is
they've kind of created recreated the
very beast they were trying to slay
hey constantine do you like trigonometry
of course what's not to love incredible
interviews hilarious raw shows plus
we're going to start doing weekly
satirical comedy like the ones that we
used to put out i'm constantly kissing
and you may remember me from my stint
hosting a kids tv show on al jazeera and
i'm francis foster a man who looks like
a cross between louis theroux and a
beaver
we are gonna start doing them but we
need your help as the show grows francis
and i are finding it increasingly
difficult to stay on top of everything
we've got to do with two interviews and
three raw shows every single week plus
loads of admin on top of that we've got
more work on than justin trudeau's
makeup artist do you miss comedy that's
actually funny comedy that pulls no
punches and isn't all about how we must
fight the structures of patriarchal
oppression by toxic straight white men
if you want real comedy you can make
that happen if we can get an extra 250
local supporters by march 15th we'll be
able to outsource a few of the
day-to-day things that we do and free up
more time to make incredible content for
you it will be funny biting satirical
and not some worthy [ __ ] telling you
what to think
[Laughter]
it's seven dollars a month which is five
pounds if you live in the civilized
world join our locals community using
the link in the description and help us
make comedy great again
and one of the things sorry francis just
to follow up on this point about how
this and i know people listening and
watching might think this is sort of
abstract economic stuff but it really
isn't and i invite them to stick with us
so
we we started out by talking about
volatility and prices of food and oil
and gas and so on and then we started
talking about derivatives and how that
is making prices less stable and making
them more unstable and am i would i be
right in thinking that bill clinton in
particular was one of the people who
removed many of the regulations that
were keeping this under control
absolutely that's right so clinton's
ultimately the guy who signs the
commodity futures modernization act in
2000 that bill had been spearheaded by
greenspan
so greenspan and larry summers who is
then the treasury secretary as well who
now larry summers could have been
resurrected now it's back in the public
public debate
these were the guys who really kind of
spearheaded this and there's this very
famous
reported line and i go into this in in
the book but essentially what happened
was there was a a famous kind of battle
of the bureaucrats right there was
brooksley bourne who was head of the
cftc that regulates essentially
commodities which is where derivatives
in the u.s regulatory system fall under
and there have been a few of these kind
of detonations
so procter and gamble in the 1990s had
lost i think maybe tens of millions
hundreds of millions in derivative bets
they just didn't understand they thought
they were buying insurance for something
and it kind of blew up in ways created
losses they didn't realize the same was
true for orange county and so brooks
deborn who's the regulator of
derivatives through the commodity
markets which is where they all derive
um in the u.s system says hang on a
minute maybe we should like look into
this whole
trillions of dollars in bets on stuff
like maybe there's something we should
look at and
um
the washington post reported an apparent
phone call for larry summers who was
then the under secretary of the treasury
made to brooksley bourne and he said
i've got 13 bankers in my office and if
they say you go along with releasing a
report that asks this question we're
going to have a u.s financial crisis
bigger than world war ii
brooksy bourne goes ahead and releases
this it wasn't a report video it was
like a white paper inviting people to
comment on regulations and there was no
global financial crisis right and
instead what happened was there was a
whole lot of really spearheaded by
greenspan a lot of kind of internal
washington uh uh wrangling they have a
big committee hearing in which they kind
of humiliate her all these guys kind of
gang up on her
she ends up being pushed out and then
larry summers and greenspan and i think
two others end up writing this report
that ends up becoming the the thing that
deregulates it and of course it's the
biggest irony that you know this ends up
causing a genuinely the biggest
financial crisis since world war ii
right it was actually
not doing what brooks deborne said that
that led to the whole housing market us
economy exploding and it happens very
quickly once they take the breaks off
the economy it happens within literally
a few years
yeah absolutely and i it because it had
already been growing right so in the
1990s already been growing but it was in
this sort of regulatory gray area and of
course that's not great right you don't
want to build a trillion dollar business
in a gray area and so 2000 that act
again it was very much focused on these
new derivatives like housing but also
betting on things like currencies
government debt and things like that and
commodities were kind of almost like an
afterthought to that process but of
course hugely important as well how much
of a part
did dare i say corruption play because
you've got these politicians
they know that the glass spiegel act is
there to protect people it's there to
protect society we brought it in now
correct me if i'm wrong after the last
great depression in the 1930s and
they're doing this at the bethesda banks
asset managers is there something
nefarious going on there or did they
genuinely think that this would be a
good move
um i think there's a lot of um
motivated reasoning going on for sure um
you know in that case in particular a
lot of this was also being driven by bob
rudin right so he was like one of the
big guys in clinton's economic team he
was also like a mentor to um
uh lauren summers and others
and you know they when they repealed
glass-steagall they said this is like
the city bank merger act i think i could
be wrong on the details here i haven't
looked at this for a while but
you know lo and behold who goes and gets
a 10 million dollar job after this you
know bob rudin right so
i think there was definitely always the
problem of rotating doors there's
absolutely no doubt between that when
you're looking at who's staffing the
regulatory agencies who's in the banks
and again this is what milton friedman
anticipated in 1962 this is like the
great irony right he absolutely says
right once you start having these big
institutions that have really got their
fingers in the markets if you staff them
with bankers you know they're going to
start governing in the interest of
bankers
um and that was even a comment made by
um
an appointee i've got his name has split
my mind right now but there was an
appointee that um bill clinton made like
under greenspan in the federal reserve
and he's a lifelong academic he had no
interest in being a banker
um didn't wasn't a banker before wasn't
a bank after but he also kind of said
it's a bit it's quite human right like
even if you even like like him he's like
he didn't want that career he didn't
want that payday but he said it's like
you're being marked by the market as a
as a central banker you put out in a
statement you maybe you pull a policy
leave or maybe it's interest vote
something else and you get instant
response from the market right and it's
like you it can be difficult to not pay
attention to that right you're
constantly being graded and it's just
human nature to want good marks right
you want the stock market to like you
you want to say something at the federal
reserve
and see the stock market sort of go up
but it also encourages a sense of
short-termism to short-termism doesn't
it because like you said you want the
stock market to go up but you don't
think about the stock market two or
three years or five or ten years down
the line
you're thinking about the stock market
now it creates an immediacy in the way
you think
it absolutely does and greenspan was
constantly sort of criticized because
the the ultimate expression of this of
this logic was was was talked about
during greenspan and on wall street they
called it the green span put option
which essentially meant that whenever
the stock market went down greenspan
would cut interest rates and throw fuel
on the fire and he sort of
criticized for fueling the tech bubble
of the 1990s and then the housing bubble
housing over the 2000s what i wanted to
do in my book though was to sort of
take a
to to look outside the united states
because of course what's happening
united states impacts the globe right
the stock market's important but to be
honest most holders of u.s stocks are
either u.s citizens or other u.s
entities whereas the chicago merson
trial exchange has an absolute global
impact right to the price that people
are paying for food and fuel globally is
absolutely outweighed
uh uh impact by by that and also the
federal reserve right so these sort of
things all kind of because um
commodities are denominated in dollars
right a lot of petrodollars get recycled
in the u.s financial system and so what
actually happens is you have the u.s
decisions that are made internally to
the u.s for u.s reasons have these kind
of global ripple effects and that's kind
of what the book wants to explore it's
saying yes okay there was the uh housing
bubble there was an explosion of housing
derivatives there was the global
financial crisis and that's a story
that's now well well known we have
various hollywood movies there's lots of
books but there was other detonations as
well and the price of food and oil that
didn't stop in 2008 they kept going
throughout the decades and they're
happening again right now and these were
kind of global events and as you said at
the beginning we're not talking about
them because it wasn't considered a
crisis in europe or the us at the time
and what i wanted to do the book and i
go on this kind of gonzo adventures lots
of kind of war zones like we should have
been in or caracas was to kind of really
highlight that like that story with the
video game it was like what does it mean
to live in one of these places in
venezuela
that happened because the oil prices
collapsed in 2014 that was the first
reason and then secondly of course um
enormous sanctions put on the regime in
2017 by uh trump um was venezuela miss
merit um mismanaged before sure it was
but was it you know mismanaged so much
worse than these oil economies i mean i
don't think so
all right so look the story the
narrative of this conversation is
essentially this
commodity prices that is food oil gas
etc
cause
instability
volatility of those prices fluctuations
random changes that are significant etc
cause instability of one form of another
if dictators who sell oil suddenly can
get a better price for the oil they're
much more likely to to execute their
expansionist plans and likewise if food
prices spike than people in poorer
countries uh are likely to protest rebel
overthrow the government etc which
causes instability
a second piece is that that instability
and that volatility in particular in
recent years is caused by the fact that
we've taken some
some irresponsible deregulation that's
happened in the last 20 20 years
particularly which has facilitated that
and so we've deregulated that is causing
instability it's causing war
what the hell did we do about it
this is a really great question and it's
incredibly urgent right because
commodity prices are surging again
we could be looking at another global
food crisis with the instability that
comes with it i also you know we've been
talking about things been happening 10
years ago it's important to remember i
think you know in kazakhstan in january
the government was deposed over food
sorry fuel prices doubling right this
isn't even like
literally like a month and a half old
right this is something which happened
which happened this year
so you've got of course the human
suffering element
you've got the political stability
element as you mentioned you've then got
this war element which
and of course these things of course
begin to cascade with each other
they tend to feed into each other
the most immediate thing um in the
current crisis would be you know uh make
sure we get through to people because
there's two separate issues here which
get confused
so one is global prices right and as we
mentioned that there's a
way in which prices in reality can sort
of diverge from each other into robert
schiller he's the great economist of
bubbles and
he was essentially explaining to me is
how all price movements are the result
of stories right
friedman and other you know pro-market
people would say well they're the good
stories they're the rational stories
because if you've got a crappy story you
know you'll lose out right if you go and
bet on a two-legged horse right
bad for you you're gonna you're going to
be kicked out of that market you're not
going to last very long so this argument
is that's not quite the case in in
reality that kind of bad stories have a
way of persisting and if you're in on
the bad story first you can still kind
of you can still make money out of it
two examples of that would be um 2008
2010 so 2008
there's a global food crisis
um
that year and the year previously had
seen more food ever produced in history
2010 they were wildfires across russia
there was again the financial press you
can look at this stuff up right in the
archives there was always kind of
hysteria of global shortages of wheat
but the u.s that year had a bumper crop
again more food was produced in 2010
than mu in history but price is doubled
nevertheless right because it was those
stories that got factored into prices
and sure the price does come down when
the new information comes out the mark
itself corrects but as kane said in the
long run we're all dead right so the
short term really matters in a lot of
these places especially for people who
are spending most of their income on
food or
calling it like a living on the edge of
chaos right you just need a little nudge
maybe to kind of to kind of push you
over and i think that's really important
because what we're seeing right now and
each of these markets is slightly
different oil gas and food so i don't
want to
lock them all together necessarily but
maybe for expediency i will um is that
it's not quite clear that especially for
oil and wheat we we are seeing shortages
yet
right so
russian oil is still being pumped and
still being sold russian natural gas is
still flowing into into europe in fact
it's now higher than it was before the
war
um
the fears over ukrainian wheat and
actually some russian wheat not getting
out as exports to a particularly the
middle east and sub-saharan africa they
desperately need
um
that [ __ ] and the supply chain hasn't
actually broken yet it will do
but of course it's not coming out on
like a daily basis right it's not quite
how it works not only that the chinese
and the us have gargantuan reserves
right so it's not like that's the only
wheat we have is stuck in ukraine if we
don't get that
and so i think what we need to do is
we'll separate these two issues out
one is we need to make sure that there's
price stability
and there's some really interesting work
being done now on a kind of
you say price controls people's like
heads explode but like there are ways to
kind of regulate prices i mean of course
electricity prices and things like that
are regulated in britain other countries
anyway right we can have some regulation
of prices to kind of restore sanity
this is by the way really normal for
wartime right world war ii and so forth
but you can't have markets markets can't
synthesize this information right like
the japanese bomb pearl harbor oh no
there's no more voodoo we're going to
lose the next day
roosevelt says something
there's the information environment is
too uncertain right for prices to really
do their job of like helping us organize
the economy so i definitely think we
need to make sure that the volatility is
reduced whether that's
uh deeper regulations on on restoring
the roosevelt era things or maybe some
new inventions i'm sort of
be
reading about but
that is all almost secondary to this
need for the physical markets right the
markets aren't functioning correctly
they don't during wartime that's
completely normal and we need to
remember that the state needs to ship
there's the the state needs to
sorry the state needs to step in right
buy it in the u.s they need to get those
reserves somewhere then to put them on
boats they need to send them to places
like libya syria
yemen even bangladesh these are all
countries that are normally dependent on
ukrainian wheat and we just need to get
it to them the u.s by the way has had a
long history of doing this so during the
cold war um it was a big part of their
cold war strategy was to basically give
either cheap or massively subsidized uh
bread to
middle eastern countries to kind of stop
them from siding with the soviet union
and during the oil crisis of the 70s you
know kissinger would call them up the
egyptians and the syrians and be like
we're going to color for your food
unless you do what we want and they told
them to go to hell but that's another
story so we've when we're talking about
a marshall plan
we need this right now with food right
we really really really can't wait we
need to start talking about physical
markets physical bushels of wheat we
need to get them on physical boats and
and we just send them there we can't
just leave it to the market to do it
because
you know there's there's quite simply
there's too much uncertainty right like
why would you want to necessarily if
you're a private investor or a private
merchant one want to get involved in
this because the walker then tomorrow
the war could end in three years and and
we can't expect the private sector to to
to do this and so europe and the u.s
really needs to step in and make sure we
don't have another global food crisis
okay but that's the short term what
about the structural issue which is the
the deregulation that we've had is going
to keep causing price and stability what
do we need to do to fix that sure so we
need to go back to some version of the
of the roosevelt era
if it rules for sure we need to
basically anchor these markets assuming
there's peace time might let's just
assume there's a ceasefire tomorrow
we're back to the wonderful days of 2021
that was so like amazing
um let's go back to that beautiful era
of last year where we were all happy and
rainbow smiles and so forth
rainbow smiles behind martial yeah by
mars exactly so very good at that i mean
that's just it's just a complete
no-brainer right we need to basically
anchor markets in like the real world
look markets are amazing things i'm not
going to deny this right like i'm not an
anti-market person when markets operate
they're um
incredible engines of of stability and
trade and you know these these are great
things the stake cannot control markets
this this large for the most part
um but the the the thing that i also
learned from another nobel prize-winning
economist uh joseph stiglitz who i
interviewed is that markets need very
specific conditions to operate correctly
right so there's a there's a kind of a
sense you might read when you read the
most of pro market
i i ideologues that you know markets are
kind of natural inventions that kind of
you put
mankind on desert island and you kind of
came back in a year you'd find a kind of
beautiful free market and it would only
be if some kind of evil government state
got established that it would all sort
of go wrong interference and so forth
i actually have seen those kinds of
anarchic markets in venezuela and iraq
and they are just it's feudalism right
it's just the guy with guns is the
person who who actually kind of controls
this and you can kind of see a kind of
markets operating outside the state and
there and they're really not pretty
pretty things
so what you need is you need a kind of a
state architecture to make sure that
markets are grounds in reality i suppose
that's the message of my book right it's
saying like sure we can have prices
prices can coordinate markets we can
have this decentralized world but they
really should be dominated by people who
are
uh involved in the physical production
of this just in the same way with the
hospital right we you know you go to the
hospital and you would want the people
who are making the decisions about your
care to be doctors nurses other people
with professional degrees you don't
necessarily want it to be
a hedge fund in singapore right who's
bought the hospital and is now deciding
but that is actually the reality of a
lot of private hospitals and uh
nursing homes in in in in the uk right
we had this huge boom and bust of
restaurants when restaurants like
batista valerie or byron berg or
whatever got bought up by private equity
massive expansions again it wasn't
rooted in the real world right this was
money flowing in
looking for yield it wasn't people
making rational decisions about the uk
health the sort of uk restaurant market
these weren't like
chefs going oh i know what we knew we
never made another byron burger in this
in this suburb of london it was no it
was a template copied and pasted by
these different funds and it destroyed
much of the uk restaurant industry right
because you had massive over-expansion
events went up the business model
collapses and now thousands of people
are unemployed and i suppose that the
message
the sort of
the positive message my book is is that
you know we don't need to go back that
far right it's not i'm not giving you a
history about the pre-history of
civilization and it was all wonderful
back in the stone ages and we all lived
in lives of abundance
why not go back to the go-go 80s was
that that terrible for finance you know
was that that terrible
to go back to
that era and i think that's that's that
would be a huge step in the right
direction is just to go back to the 90s
the 1980s which again wasn't even that
that long ago rupert isn't the problem
as well that we've got these
institutions that are too big to fail
and you've been talking about
institutions like black rock mentioning
these huge songs and and i started to
get anxious i'll go well if that goes
you know like like lehman brothers what
effect is that going to have on society
it's a really great question because i
think the lehman brothers
debacle was actually a turning point
rather than something that we should
fear
so lehman brothers i think in kind of
sort of
central banking law is the biggest
mistake they ever made in living memory
why was letting lehman brothers fail
because the way in which these markets
work as i mentioned that all about
narratives part of narrative is
confidence right and to keep everything
kind of going everyone's got to believe
there's something happening tomorrow
right that's kind of how it has to work
and so when neiman brothers goes down
the confidence collapse and then the
entire financial system
um is threatened not just because you're
gonna get you're gonna get
all kinds of different kind of domino
effects right so imagine building the
most complicated
eight dimensional jenga thing that you
could imagine right lehman brothers was
pulling out one of those things and the
whole thing goes down
and i think what the central banks
learnt
was not ever let that happen again
2020 march
um pandemic is really hitting right
you're seeing the first kind of
shutdowns again radical uncertainty
markets don't know how to respond you
get what they call this dash for cash
global globally how is
dollars stored they're stored in u.s
treasuries because you get a yield from
it right so it's as good as money that's
why people love holding u.s treasuries
it's as good as cash but you get money
every year
um
and so there was this huge sell-off in
the u.s traffic market now unbeknownst
to most people there were all sorts of
hedge funds playing all kinds of bets
and they were essentially
arbitraging uh different kinds of prices
between treasuries right there's futures
treasuries prices
don't understand the mechanics of this
but basically there was a whole bunch of
uh trading that was happening highly
leveraged around these u.s treasuries
and because there was this sort of shock
event of a sell-off of uh treasuries
which underneath normal circumstances
never happened
suddenly this whole kind of system goes
hey why why so these hedge funds can't
pay the collateral calls the banks stop
calling in the loans and again you get
like one of these django things where
you pull the piece out and uh jerome
powell the uh chair of the federal
reserve just basically prints a trillion
dollars right he basically they press a
button on the computer federal reserve
trillion dollars of us treasuries
appears and suddenly the whole system
kind of keeps keeps going
um
there was no lehman brothers moment and
i think when you look at what the
central banks think about and talk about
they're trying always to identify where
that may come from um so one that
they're very much interested at the
moment is climate change
right so
another interesting thing when you think
about the real world and the financial
world and the relationship to it when we
talk about like a housing crisis or the
housing bubble in america it's one of
the houses just disappeared right right
there's like a little physical thing
that happened that they built houses and
they just suddenly like sat on fire or
something and then they had no more
houses to sell it was really internal to
the market of finance and how these
things have been turned into assets and
how that have been baked into the
financial system
what we could see though so imagine how
terrible it was without any houses being
destroyed now imagine rising sea levels
right and suddenly you've got
big portions of miami underwater will
those prices go to zero what's going to
happen to the banks that lent the money
for the mortgages for this well all
those banks are gonna fail well what's
gonna and then immediately you have a
ripple effect and this is just let's
just take just miami right you have a
ripple effect that could destroy the
entire u.s financial system and this is
they're kind of gaming it out like war
games you know there's a lot of kind of
what-ifs like well what if sea levels
rose by this amount what if there was a
storm that destroyed u.s crops what
happened to the banks that lend the
money for those crops right so
everything kind of all arrows point back
to finance because they're the ones
lending everybody the money and
essentially what they've ended up doing
is a bit like what jerome powell is
doing is
essentially printing money and shoring
it up because they don't want to have a
rerun of the financial crisis the risk
from that is of course the classic risk
that's why they did lebanon brothers
fail is that it's this mul is this moral
hazard thing right if you're blackrock
when you're going okay we're too big to
fail whoever you want we know that if we
have you know huge investments in x or y
you know we're going to get bailed out
or there's going to be some kind of
insurance and they're actually asking
for this by the way right so there's a
big piece of finance that wants central
banks to essentially guarantee their
green investment so it's uh it's a bet
of you know heads i win tails i win
right that's kind of what they want to
sort of make the interview that seems
like a good idea take the risk kind of
gambling i'm sure that that will work
very well listen i i wish we had more
time but it's been a very interesting
conversation and uh probably the
beginning of one rather than the end of
one to be honest because this is uh this
is going to get more and more important
i feel as things go on
uh so thanks for coming on a price wars
how chaotic markets create a chaotic
world is really fascinating read i
recommend people check it out uh thanks
for coming on we're going to ask you a
couple of questions from our locals only
supporters that only they get to see but
before we do that we as always have one
more question for you which is what's
the one thing we're not talking about
but we really should be well i'm going
to piggyback on what i've already said
um at the beginning and say we're not
looking for mazes so
i encourage everybody to watch loads of
horror movies because they're great
templates for thinking about the world
right you load up twitter or whatever it
feels like a kind of horror feed at
least like doom scrolling what it might
be but i think you do want a lot of
people to be killed with a chainsaw on
there as well
well i'm not going to say what i want to
see
because that would be illegal nail guns
for me i love when you reach for the
nail gun that's always a good scene um
is that we've adopted the tropes of a
horror movie right so that's it's putin
is the monster what's he really thinking
has he gone mad for two years and the
pandemic reading crazy russian
historians
maybe has lady hasn't i don't know right
right so we like to kind of monsters are
fun they're grotesque they've got great
personalities we can kind of read the
tea leaves into them um
but the key to every great monster movie
is the maze right because um imagine
alien just takes place in a big
spaceship that's just like a a
basketball court right it's not gonna
last very long is it right you know
she's just hope he's gonna be there and
the aliens is going to come and just
kill her right now you've got to create
a maze you've got to create barriers and
structures so that you've got chase and
it's exciting and you could think about
um the shining right you've got jack
nicholson right not just running around
the hotel corridors but he literally
goes into a labyrinth right that's the
final scene that kubrick has running
around a literal maze which is a
call back to the minotaur in the maze
right in greek greek mythology or zombie
movies dawn the dead it all takes place
in a more you've got to kind of run
around the mall and i think that's what
gets obscured in the news is we don't
look enough at the kind of structures
it's like what is constraining these
monsters and also what's enabling them
and i think ultimately that's the
that's what's going to help us uh
uh keep them engaged it's not saying
what is it that putin wants or what is
it that putin will accept and trying to
get inside his head because to be honest
i think it's a fool's errand i mean who
actually knows this apart from himself
but we know that his power comes from
structure right he we
we know what that structure is it's
based largely in the in the commodity
markets and that's and that's really
what we can do and i think we could take
that that's just one current example but
you could apply that across the ball to
sort of whenever you're seeing a kind of
horror in the news which part of the
world it's coming from is to always
think about what is the maze here what
is the what is the architecture of
opportunity and constrained how has this
been allowed to happen why is it
happening now and why hasn't it happened
in the past and i think it's from then
which we then begin to understand like
why these monsters have emerged
perfectly for russell thank you so much
for coming on thanks for having me yeah
if people want to find your book or they
want to find you online where is the
best place to do that
well you can just wherever you are just
look for price wars cultic markets are
creating chaotic world and i'm on
twitter as well on rupa underscore
russell
fantastic stuff fantastic we thank you
guys for watching and listening we'll
see you very soon with another brilliant
episode like this one or raw show all of
which go out at 7pm uk time and for
those of you who like your trigonometry
on the go it's also available as a
podcast take care and see you soon guys
is behind the commodity traders are
their actions directed solely by the
profit motive or are there for example
government actors influencing their
choice of which commodity markets to
destabilize
[Music]
you